there is no place where advertising is
more relevant than in the cigarette
industry brand loyalty is extremely high
so it's important to a cigarette company
that they're the first one is biggie
smoke it's also important to distract
the customer from the obvious value
bargain that their product will
eventually kill you necessity has made
these companies masters at advertising
and until 1970 when cigarette
advertisements were banned nobody was
better at this advertising than Marlboro
no cigarette or packaging is more
recognizable more American more smoke
than this one but Marlboro did more than
just Windy advertising more with arrival
they changed advertising forever and how
did they do it
well when Philip Morris started the
company in 1847 it was aimed at women it
didn't work very well at first however
in the 1950s when new studies came out
that smoking caused cancer many tobacco
companies started to panic and change
tactics it was at this point that
Marlboro made a key move they switched
their advertising tactics and Men and
became the first-ever lifestyle
advertisers okay pop before we go
further it's very important that you
know exactly what lifestyle advertising
looks like the good news is you're
already super familiar with lifestyle
advertising even if you don't know it it
is when a commercial tries to tie its
product to something else in your life a
feeling and attribute satisfaction the
list is endless like when an energy
drink ties itself to extreme athleticism
or a camera to adventure a soda to
happiness a car to love or a phone to
more than just a phone once you're
familiar with term you'll notice it's
the most popular and effective form of
advertising that we know of but it
wasn't always this way
roll the clock back 60 years and people
had a much different idea of how to
advertise this product take a look at
this camel add from the
our mild can a cigarette be well I'm a
smoking camels for 20 years I know
they're milder they really taste great
yes camels are so mild that in a test of
hundreds of people who smoked only
camels for 30 days throat specialists
making weekly examinations reported not
one single case the throat irritation
due to smoking camels why is this ad so
unconvincing while everything is fact
and product-oriented by my thing over
their thing because all our researchers
say so but the truth is most of us don't
care about that research I'm buying a
pack of cigarettes to be cool not
because doctors say it's more smooth
than a competitor's so in the 50s when
Marlboro changed sexes they also changed
their advertising strategy by selling
their product as a symbol rather than
just on the merits of its design they
did this by creating a smoking cowboy
known as a Malvar again the Marlboro Man
was designed to be the archetype of
management he was hard working and
living free so with that last commercial
in mind watch this commercial and notice
how much less screen time the mall
borough cigarette gets and how the focus
of the ad has shifted away from an
isolated product to encompass a feeling
of a rough rugged real life in other
words they weren't just selling
cigarettes but rather a feeling of
freedom and adventure and there's maybe
a slight irony here that most Cowboys
did not smoke at the time but it dipped
but most people didn't care within one
year of this campaign Marlboro went from
owning less than 1% of the market to
being the fourth largest cigarette
company in the world and within four
more years it became the number one
selling cigarette in the world and it
remains that way to this day the
Marlboro Man is a legend in advertising
and shape the future of advertising
forever and I think no matter what your
stance on cigarettes are we can all
learn from Marlboros lesson to help us
communicate with others people don't
want to be sold a product people want to
be sold of feeling a connection
something that's worth more than the
paper that is printed on
so it's in the spirit of learning that I
decided to change my subscriber segment
for this video to be a little more
lifestyle
[Music]
you